I'm the one who calling my own shop I'm
the one calling my own shop I know you
think I'm a dummy and yeah I'm kind of
coming I'm the one calling my own shop
I'm gonna hear my million from Stephen
Bannon to tell you guys what the hell is
that we've been planning okay this book
here but still I get to put my hand in
all right it's all about to be fair I'm
not even there my attention span is so
it's going to see me short shiny object
whoa where the hell was I my train of
thought inexplicable for alex reece so
my mind is addled the new york times of
take out a rattle I'm saddled with the
job I never wanted man I do what talk a
way to do it I don't have a clue through
it let's be banner do it the plan is to
catch in presidential fame and make a
couple bucks for everyone with my name
hashtag MA GJ easy d America first [ __ ]
refugees economies that run off a grift
agree rebound kelly and ryan on the damn
TV pet release the facts are Edna be the
blast be blackmailed me with tapes of
peace and I won't ever show my pack
still some acts at me so far we have a
constitution like a DNC access bow down
to me at least i think so i haven't read
it I can't read I'll complain the press
treats me unpleasantly recklessly cuz
that is month end to see I'm the one
calling my own shop I'm the one who's
calling my own stuff I know you think
I'm Italian yeah I'm kind of telling me
I'm the one calling my own shop I'm the
one calling my own shop I'm the one who
calling my old shop I know you think I'm
assuming it yes I'm kind of told me I'm
the one calling my old shop time to take
a shot